alright guys so today I'm gonna talk
about something that I have wanted to do
for a very long time I just never knew
how I could do it but today I came up
with how I can do this thing and that of
course is how to fake my own death
because who wouldn't want to fake their
own death it's awesome you could see how
just how many people care about you and
people will miss you people will love
you again people who hated you will show
up to your funeral because you are now
dead now the thing is though you don't
want to be an [ __ ] when you appear
alive again you're gonna be like you
[ __ ] have me believing you were dead
you're a douchebag no don't do that
here's what you got to do you got to
show up in a way where it's like they're
shocked but they're not mad at you now
how do you do that that has been the
question forever so here's what you
first do you don't want to like fake
your own death in like a painful way
what I would do is I think something
with a dental work thingamajig I would
light my car on fire somewhere and try
to plant something that makes it seem
like I was in the car and died and I
just turn into ash that's how bad the
fire was but my clothes are still around
it's kind of like the Incredible Hulk
when his jeans expanded so then after
you let your car on fire the next thing
you should do run away for a while make
sure you have money saved up this is
gonna be quite an investment on
depending on the kind of lifestyle you
want to have over the next few weeks so
then you know like oh the girl you
wanted to get back is that the funeral
oh that hot [ __ ] that wouldn't [ __ ] you
she's at the funeral now like all the
woman you hated are gonna show up and
all the people you love are gonna show
but you're more satisfied with the fact
that the people that you hated showed up
cuz it's like that's what's up I knew
you really cared about me this whole
time and here's what you do next step
next step you can go on Hollywood makeup
on it or you could actually do it gotta
look like you were kidnapped for the
past 30 days and someone tried to frame
me that's why they faked you forget
because they were gonna keep you hostage
forever when everyone's in the church or
whatever and then you know they're all
giving their little speeches about how
awesome you are and then the girl who
said she'd never get back with you is
like I said I've got a bag with them is
there so then you show up and you're all
like
you look like someone kicked the [ __ ]
out of you you got facial hair this is
assuming if you're a man basically you
just look like like like awful but kind
of sexy at the same time you know like
one of movie stars doing this when you
show up first thing you're gonna want to
do is like look at the person who would
talk about how much you suck and hated
you but you knew how much this person
really liked you but they've hurt your
feelings a lot and you go what are you
doing here I thought you were dead
oh so once I'm dead now you want to see
me then you walk the [ __ ] away and you
just got your revenge and then what do
you do next what are you next people are
gonna be like what's happening but you
don't it would be like guys I'm alive
it's okay no you play it like a badass
and you just look around the crowd and
then you you get into the front and then
you say some badass thing like whoever
kept me hostage for the past thirty days
I'm now free I don't know if you're in
this room or not
but if you are I'm gonna find you I have
a very particular set of skills and that
saves you from like you know them never
solving the case of who you know
kidnapped you and you're gonna be famous
you're gonna be in the news people are
gonna love you again they're gonna be
happier alive they're gonna be a total
badass who saved themselves from being a
hostage anyway that is how I would fake
my own death
why are you comment below and tell me
how you'd fake your own death